good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the third and final panel of this
confidence of this conference which is
the only one that has a title which is
potentially somewhat uplifting namely
can it happen here question mark and
what can we do about it
so I'm Ian Shapiro and I'm happy to be
moderating this panel we do have seven
speakers who we will call each to speak
for up to ten minutes as the names
appear on the program in that order so
we will start with Julia Azari from
Marquette University then Emily Bazelon
from the New York Times and the Yale Law
School David Frum from the Atlantic Tom
Ginsburg from USC of Chicago and also as
he Huck I believe the pronunciation is
also from University of Chicago Francis
Lee from the University of Maryland and
Yosh a MOOC from Harvard so welcome all
and without further ado Julia every
couple of seconds so I'm gonna talk a
little bit about Trump in a broader
historical context and I want to start
this out by saying that typically when I
address an audience to talk about Trump
and I'm here with fellow academics and
people who write for elite journalistic
outlets in a mostly white context in a
mostly liberal context and we've spent
the last half a day talking about the
problems posed by Trump supporters and
the Trump administration assuming that
these are folks that are politically
distant from ourselves and from the
political tradition that we align with
what I want to start by saying is that
we ought to be attuned to the fact that
the calls are coming from inside the
house that
there's more in the American political
tradition that is normal here than we
typically we typically expect and so
having started that way I'm I also want
to challenge the premise of the
wonderful people who brought me here and
the idea that there's a bright line of
democracy that periodically gets crossed
rather in the United States context Jews
what I'm going to talk about I want to
mention that the compromise is necessary
for stability and legitimacy of our
democratic institutions often coexist
with profoundly substantively
undemocratic ideas undemocratic
practices and particularly in the United
States context undemocratic practices
around race my main claim here is that
while Trump is unique in many many ways
he also represents the latest iteration
in a pattern that I see is infrequent
but long-standing
every time we have a president in the
United States who disrupts the racial
order they have a particular kind of
successor and here as I define what this
what this successor is like I have a
bunch of hypotheses many questions and
few answers so we've heard we've heard
Trump compared with Andrew Johnson
Abraham Lincoln's successor impeached a
racist and someone who's generally
portrayed by historians is as
temperamentally unsuited to the office
we've also seen Trump compared many
times with Richard Nixon with Nixon's
approach to to rule of law to abuse of
power and again that tends to go back to
character issues and I want to put this
into a little bit more of a structural
context and talk less about about
character so first off backlash is it is
an established feature of US democracy
we've talked about this a little bit in
the morning sessions toward the end we
really started to touch on some of the
the racial questions so this is a very
familiar dynamic that I suspect expect
that many of you have considered before
when we have
some from a racial progress in the
United States there's often a movement
of people that want to push back against
it and often that people in that
movement have some access to power I
think that's right
and I think that that's a big part of
this Johnson Nixon Trump pattern but I
think there's another part of it that's
much more challenging to pin down and
that's legitimacy that not only do we
get backlash politics but each time
there's something about the presidency
that is undermined fundamentally when
the racial order is is disrupted that
it's not only that we have a backlash
figure with some character problems but
that everything in the equilibrium of
the system is is thrown off we can't
reach majorities as I mentioned in my
memo for those of you might have had a
chance to read it I mentioned that
Johnson Nixon and now Trump all are
non-majority presidents Johnson of
course an accidental president after
Lincoln's assassination Nixon wins a
narrow plurality in 1968 as a law and
order candidate and of course Trump who
fell well shy of the popular vote
representing the biggest distortion
between the Electoral College of the
popular vote that we've seen that I
think is a feature of not just what
happens to presidential candidates in a
in a backlash context but what happens
to American politics when the racial
order is disrupted and I think that's
something that's much more difficult
both intellectually to figure out why
and what the indicators of that are and
all sort of to face up to morally and as
residents and citizens of the United
States I think that this helps us
reimagine what this institution is or
excuse me what this administration is
and why this has happened so I want to
take a second and think about the
politics of compromise that led up to
each of these disruptions the presidency
is implicated in in racial compromises
that hold the nation together and make
the nation's stable and this leads up I
think many of us are familiar with this
in the context of the civil war leading
up to the Civil War
u.s. politics is a series of
unsatisfying compromises that
increasingly lead to instability and
they really don't address the needs of
both sides of either side this came up a
few times this morning as we talked
about politics that cannot solve the
problems of the United States but I also
think this is important to think about
as we hold up compromise as a critical
Democratic value compromise doesn't
always isn't always compatible with
substantive democracy leading up to the
Civil War we see that and then with
Lincoln a refusal to engage in those in
those kinds of compromises ultimately at
the end of the Civil War around slavery
ultimately the Civil War becomes about
slavery and the racial order is upended
and it's in that context that Andrew
Johnson becomes president and tries to
use the power of the state to bring back
as much of that pre Civil War racial
order as as possible to limit the extent
to which the fundamental institutions of
the American state are changed and this
is also true to a degree in the in the
1960s so after the Civil War we get a
period of new compromises around around
race we get a new period of racial
institutions in nineteen in the 1960s
Lyndon Johnson changes that and once
again we have a successor who ends up
facing impeachment who runs on a
backlash platform and who's an on
majority president the mechanics of how
this failure of legitimacy work in each
of these cases I think is something I've
hypothesized about more than I've had a
chance to to really test so I'm open to
any suggestions about what that what
that might what might be going on there
but it seems to me that in each of these
historical instances we do see elements
of our current of our current moment
where it's not clear where to go forward
everything has been disrupted and and
uprooted and so you have a backlash
movement that doesn't exactly control
the country you have a new status quo
the the implementation of which and the
the future of which is unclear
after the after the 1960s we get a new
racial status quo in which which was
described this morning as a fuller
American democracy and I think that's
true the protection of civil and and
voting rights does fundamentally change
American politics but what I think we
all learned in the last eight years is
that it's not a post-racial order like
maybe some people expected instead we've
got a colorblind order in which once
again that power of the presidency is a
power of maintaining a certain kind of
racial power and Obama's presence in
that office challenged the connection
between whiteness and presidential power
and I think that's ultimately what what
leads us to our Trump moment there's
lots of evidence that this mattered and
we talked a whole lot this morning about
the economy the economy obviously always
drives a good deal of voting behavior
that's an important part of the story
but there's mounting evidence that races
what's driving a lot of political
attitudes today racial divisions along
both attitudinal lines and demographic
lines um if I have defined American
politics really since um since 1980 in
our in our current iteration um but in
2016 political scientist Michael tesslar
found that racial attitudes were
actually more important in determining
whether someone voted for Trump or
Clinton than they were in determining in
2008 whether someone chose Obama or or
McCain we have lots of examples of how
that's of how that mattered in electing
Trump so I've just gotten my two-minute
warning so I want to move on
having been extremely depressing about
American political political history to
talk a little bit about moving forward
and here I wanna kind of shift over to
thinking about the legitimacy that
underlies this incredible presidential
power that's been so deeply and
inextricably linked with untenable
racial compromise and with whiteness in
the United States what are our
possibility is moving forward I think
that history suggested the most likely
possibility moving forward
is it will move into a new untenable
compromise and that will we'll have
another 40 year period of stability that
will then be interrupted and this cycle
will will repeat we usually suggest when
we talk about political cycles in the
United States we usually think of them
in terms of stagnation that a 40-year
period by the end one party's ideology
has become stagnant their coalition has
become stagnant or doesn't make sense
anymore and that's when we get
instability and I'm suggesting I said
that instability is really rooted in in
disruption and I think that that's
something to think about also going
forward is to have an eye on this
dynamic between stagnation and and
disruption and then when we disrupt
these morally untenable compromises it
really does throw off the rest of the
system
I think this leads us to some different
questions about rehabilitating the
United States system and I do think that
rehabilitating is the right is the right
choice of language that we might want to
think about not just how to revert to
some kind of status quo of a functional
American democracy but how to break out
of this pattern of creating an untenable
compromise and instead create an
institutional stability worth preserving
[Applause]
it's a pleasure to be here I think I'm
going to play the card of being the
journalist on the panel with David he'll
also play that card I know I'm a simple
country lawyer
uh and talk a little bit about the
challenge of journalistic norms in the
Trump era which is something that I
think after the election in particular I
know I've been wrestling with a lot of
my colleagues have been talking and
thinking about a lot and I have
certainly in hearing from people who you
know consume journalism in particular
readers of the New York Times I think
there's a kind of sense of urgency about
this after the election a couple of
times I was speaking before an audience
perhaps not as erudite as this one and
not talking particularly about the New
York Times at all and found that what
people really wanted to express to me
was rage at the paper and that the whole
profession a sense of that we had failed
and that Trump was really our fault and
I think there are completely legitimate
critiques to be weighed to be mounted
both about journalism before the
election and about the times as coverage
but what I think is more important now
in some ways I don't need to be ducking
but I'm more interested in what we do
since the election kind of going forward
how do we handle this presidency and and
are we at risk of overcorrecting as much
as we are at not being presenting the
alarm alarming possibilities enough and
I think that that is the kind of
constant tension for the press this
question of holding on to our role
making sure we stay within what you know
the profession feels is a kind of band
of normalcy but at the same time
acknowledging and recognizing and really
digging into the way that this is a
different kind of president and I don't
think that we have come up with
particularly satisfying answers on that
front as a consumer of journalism I
often feel the most frustrated with
television news with this to this regard
I think there's a way in which the very
lucrative cable format of a roundtable
where people are arguing is itself kind
of a form of disinformation
and and yet something that is you know
completely continued since the election
but I do think there is also a danger in
the press getting out in front too far
of changing norms um and so I thought I
would talk a little bit about two areas
kind of our use of language and then our
role as kind of predictors or
triangulate or is imagining what happens
next so in the language realm
you know headlines are often our biggest
challenge it's one thing when you can
read all the layers and nuance of a
thousand or twelve hundred word story
and it's another thing to have to
summarize that point of view really
quickly at the top and so after the
election as I was also watching The
Times to see how we were changing or
remaining the same I found myself
wanting clearer headlines so for example
the day that Scott Pruett was chosen as
the EPA nominee the initial headline
said climate change skeptic and there
was a lot of I remember myself thinking
like I don't think that goes far enough
what about the word denier which seems
clear and which seemed warranted I think
if I had to defend the editorial choices
that were being made there was a sense
again of not getting ahead of not losing
our broader audience
ideologically to the extent that we have
won by being seen as two extremists and
too partisan I think another example of
this is the term alright which the
pressed completely went for and you know
when we did that we did that because we
like to call groups by the words that
they choose for themselves so you know
when the alt-right came up with this
descriptor the press was happy to have
that word to use and also you know it's
um then this is my problem with it
there's a kind of lightheartedness to it
sort of catchy slogan and it felt like a
new thing which we in the press love new
things too much but I felt myself in
describing for example the website
Breitbart that there was a way in which
this term all right
was not
really capturing what was going on on
that site wasn't really an accurate
rendition of the thinking being
expressed of really what it stood for in
its connections and so I was working on
a piece and I used the term white
nationalists to describe Breitbart and
it got taken out not by my editor but
actually by the legal review that The
Times did for this piece and I went to
bat for a white nationalist because I
felt like that I had shown that I was
providing evidence in the story for the
kinds of attributes of Breitbart that
merited that designation and that there
was a way in which being too careful in
describing Breitbart giving them too
much deference and getting to choose how
they were described was itself not fully
informing our readers not really being
as clear and candid as we should be in
describing that site I'm pretty sure I
won that battle though now in this
moment I can't completely remember and
then the other challenge I think for us
has been just when something happens and
it seems like it's unprecedented what
how do we make that clear
so one way we make that clear as we use
the word unprecedented all the time
right everything is remarkable there
this is like another word that I feel
like I read all the time or striking or
unusual and those words are safe for
journalists because they sort of you
know Harold you should be paying
attention without saying like horrible
or you know crazy or mad when in fact
that is probably often what we mean and
I am not sure anymore whether I think
those words are really useful the more
they are used the more they themselves
become part of the new normal and I
think the less people maybe pay
attention to them I'm not really sure
what to do about that dilemma though
because when we call things you know
crazy or terrible we are at least in the
news page of the New York Times and most
mainstream outlets kind of stepping
outside of our role and and then again
we have this
overcorrecting so the last thing I
wanted to mention was this issue of
prediction so I was wrestling with this
right after the election as Jeff
Sessions was being proposed as the
nominee for attorney general I decided I
wanted to write about the Justice
Department to me it seemed remarkable
striking unprecedented unusual to have
Jeff Sessions as the Attorney General
someone who had been deemed to kind of
tarred by racist remarks to be confirmed
as a judge back in the mid 1980s but the
way I wanted to kind of figure out what
it really meant to have Jeff Sessions as
Attorney General is to think about how
the Justice Department has handled civil
rights in particular for different
Republican presidency it's like what
happens to the Civil Rights Division as
it goes back and forth between
Democratic and Republican presidencies
and so I did a lot of reporting I knew
something about the 80s Justice
Department I really didn't know very
much at all about George HW and and
connecting Reagan to the first Bush to
the second Bush demonstrated some really
interesting shifts and tensions that I
think align with some of what Julia was
talking about in terms of seeing our
history of changing values and changing
ways of approaching race in different
presidencies as having a great deal of
impact and a great deal of shifting
before Trump ever showed up and once I
had that reporting under my belt I felt
much more comfortable in thinking okay
so now I know what conservative
principles in the Civil Rights Division
have been tried before for example in
the area of voting we'd seen previous
moments particularly under george w bush
where voter fraud becomes suddenly a
priority for the Justice Department in a
way that is probably why I would say is
really not necessary in terms of how
frequently it happens which is to say
very rarely but it came up as a big
issue it actually caused a lot of
scandal in the early 2000s and so
knowing about that history made me more
confident
if sessions takes over what are we
likely to see and the sort of satisfying
part of that kind of journalism is that
it's trying to use the historical
context and kind of the tools the other
tool or other tools that I use as a
journalist of talking to the people who
are likely to be the decision-makers or
are kind of watching to see how things
are gonna change and then also you know
using all that history but then trying
to make some prediction trying to move
forward in a way that feels to me like
it's still grounded in the reporting I
get very nervous when I'm predicting
something based on just my own kind of
sense of what is gonna happen because
really who cares about that
uh so you know two clues I think the the
question that we're all still wrestling
with and we just won't be able to tell
until more time has passed is whether
the press is doing a good enough job of
identifying what is new and different
and what the threats are to the American
democracy without kind of overreacting
in a way that itself causes its own
identity and its own role in the
democracy to be changed in a sense if
the press becomes less creditable
because we are attacking Trump too much
we are assuming things about him that
are turn out not to be true then that
will be more damage that he's kind of
done through us and that seems like a
good thing to avoid thank you
[Applause]
so thank you mom so there goes my
opening gag sorry David uh speaking of
gags one of the biggest impediments to
understanding and appreciating through
the drama of some of the events that is
that are going on in Washington is there
frequently farcical nature that how can
it be that things are alarming when they
are also so frequently funny so just to
put this in context in the past 48 hours
we have seen the Secretary of State at
the urgent demand and insistence of the
press in the United States hold a press
conference to not deny that he called
the president a [ __ ] and then the
president understandably dissatisfied
with this response the next morning in a
rage tweeted a demand that the Senate
Intelligence Committee hold hearings on
what the Secretary of State had called
the president a [ __ ] that's pretty
funny
and maybe the laughs get you through I
want to start my talk with a historical
analogy and I'm mindful one of the
professor's I had when I was a student
here many years ago Roberto Lopez had a
saying that I once I've repeated
probably 10,000 times and its wisdom
never seeks - never escapes me that was
the warning history never repeats itself
said professor Lopez it only appears to
do so to those who do not pay attention
to details our situation is always new
but I am going to I want to involve
invoke this analogy not as an example of
history repeating itself it is a way of
thinking about something and a way of
thinking about something that may be a
little uncomfortable for some of the
people in this room as Professor
Schneider said it is often difficult to
see things when you are in them so I'm
going to talk about something that many
of the people in this room part in in
the years after World War two the United
States and his Democratic friends faced
an extremist challenge in the force of a
global communist movement both abroad
and at home and this movement met/met
work both by external subversion and by
internal revolutionary activity it was
weaker in the United States than in many
other places people
didn't really know that it was hard to
have a good sense of the scope of how
intentions danger was and in many places
of the world this danger was obviously
very extreme it took over my force under
where the Soviet armies had been and it
worked by subversion in places like
chuckle savatya and nearly so in France
in Italy the governments of the Western
world the Democratic world met this
challenge with two basic tactics the
first was a policy of confrontation
often armed confrontation that communist
parties were communist armies were met
by to containment deterrence and
sometimes outright conflict communist
movements inside the countries were
subjected to a great deal of repression
but they joined this policy of
confrontation to a policy of concession
that where communist parties were
battening on authentic grievances these
these grievances were met with
concessions of which the two most
important or decolonization communist
parties were often strong in colonized
areas Colin Erica so especially the
pressure the United States colonized
areas were decolonized and through
building the building of social
insurance States after World War two
the fear of unemployment in old age and
poverty in sickness these were real
feelings that people had and if the only
people would offer a solution to that
problem where the Communists then people
would turn to the communists we face in
the Western world not just in the United
States but in Europe as well a new
extremist movement and we can call it
the Albright we can call it Nationals
populism we can call it neo-fascism we
can call it whatever we want the
grievance it feeds on is the cultural
and economic shock of mass migration
from the poor world to the Western world
I think the consensus of many people on
the liberal side is the way to deal with
this extremist movement is with a policy
of confrontation only they are wrong
they must be scolded and they must be
told that they are completely mistaken
and no concessions at all and so in
describing the ways in which the Trump
administration is dangerous its attitude
toward immigration has been taken not as
a source of its strength but as its most
odious marker and the thing to be most
confronted and I would like to suggest
that you think about this in a different
way and that we find in dealing with the
grievances that animate the rising tide
of extremism across the Western world
some of the wisdom of the generation of
1945 to 1960 and understand theirs there
is it's there some concessions that have
to be made here if you want to move away
the sources of power and dynamism and
strength from the extremist movements
that threaten your democratic
institutions I notice when this is all
right this is a hard thought to process
um Daniel sublet whose book I so
lavishly reviewed and whose wisdom I
really cherish and admire in his list of
norm violations in the run-up to Donald
Trump I mean I'm a Republican so I
noticed it was the kind of democratic
heavy list all the norm violations were
committed by Republicans and I will
admit the situation is asymmetrical that
what the Republicans have done in the
period from 2000 to 2016 was more and
worse than what the Democrats did and in
particular the threat to put the United
States into default unless they won
their every single demand they had in
the budget negotiation that was an
unprecedented thing and really dangerous
a mark of how this country was is
tumbling down the stairs toward ever
more extreme behaviors ever more
willingness to contemplate
out-of-the-ordinary measures in order to
get your way but here's runner up to
that the second most important or
violation of the period min second-most
important executive branch second most
important normal violation the most
important executive branch norm
violation was President Obama's
immigration orders you'll remember that
in the Obama's first term he was
repeatedly pressed can you do some kind
of executive action on the illegal alien
population
I took a Tali I've written a book about
this I find I have found and I'm not a
great researcher six specific instances
for President Obama described this
action as illegal as a violation of
presidential authority as something that
was absolutely not to be thought of I'm
not a king he was a I do not have this
power but as the 2012 election got
closer and closer and as he became more
nervous about because remember it's 2012
we had to tie the economy looked really
strong
in the early part of 2011 and then it
began to slow down in the second half of
2011 in the early parts of 2012 you look
like the economy might be stalling and
so it might be an unfriendly moment
President Obama issued the first and two
years later before the 2014 elections he
issued the second of an executive order
that legalized in one case about 800,000
people in the second case a group of
about 5 million people in a way that he
himself had described as lawless and the
courts agreed by the way at least that
the 2012 measure is still on the books
but the 2014 measure was thrown out by
district district courts circuit courts
and then by for for decision of the
United States Supreme Court why is that
so important that that issue that sense
that the barriers of the country were
down was a powerfully animating force in
the Donald Trump campaign that's obvious
after it was all over after the campaign
ended and Donald Trump was elevated to
the presidency the immigration debate
was reported on according to a certain
convention this is the way we grind up
if you could identify that the
participant complaining about mass
migration had somehow been an economic
loser their wages had been in pinch Don
or they'd be crowded out of an emergency
room then the complaint was fair if it
was about money you could complain if it
was a sense of cultural displacement or
lost power or status of procedure
absolutely out of bounds and if it was a
sense of I'm a citizen and it means
something that then you're dealing with
a racist or crank or worse one of the
things that as we contemplate the
strength of democracy and this
vulnerability of democracy we have to
take more seriously in my opinion that
we have done the connection that was
argued in the 19th century between the
nation-state and democratic modes of
government we we have not found a way
and I don't think we ever will to do
democratic government in any way other
than through nation states nation states
made of citizens nation states with
borders the 20 the nation state did not
have a very good run in the period from
1914 to 1945 and not even then you know
let a better
still in many ways to be left something
to be desired run from 1945 to 1989 and
so many people of goodwill saw the
answer to the problems of our time was
to weaken the nation-state in favor of
broader attachments to humanity what we
discovered instead is we've dissolved it
what we are discovering is that people
do not move from citizenship bonds to
broader box but to narrower monster
ethnicity and to race and that is what
is happening in Europe and that is what
is happening here our topic today is
what has to be done and there's a lot to
be said but I think a new politics of
the center meets the slogan America
first with all its ugly associations
with a doctrine of Americans first and
that means doing some things that draw
from the traditional political left that
is strengthening the material
connections between citizens and state
and particularly by rethinking the
social welfare state in the American
context especially in the area of health
but it also means state strengthening
the idea of citizenship by putting
citizenship first and doctrine were
sharply the line between those who
belong to the polity and those who don't
those who have entered the polity on in
legitimate ways and those who have
sought entry in illegitimate ways and
forcing that barrier to make it clear to
all that the people who have done well
in a world in which fewer and fewer do
that still remember the people have not
done so well thank you
[Applause]
to Emily to do something unprecedented
we just sit here and give my comments
because I've jumped on me and just
thrown my back so might make the
comments that both Tom and I are going
to make are based upon a paper and book
that we have that we have been working
on concerning the legal and
constitutional credit books of
democratic backsliding our comparative
advantage is as lawyers and in
particular as comparative
constitutionalists Tom is a political
scientist they won't even let me play
one on TV the question that I want to
ask or that I will ask in my comments is
how does the US Constitution of 1787
meet or not meet the threat of
democratic backsliding and we know a
little bit about the nature of that
threat by looking comparatively at
Hungary Poland Venezuela Turkey and
seeing the legal and institutional
pathways along which backsliding
proceeds in those jurisdictions and then
asking all those pathways available in
the United States
given the current constitutional Center
and in brief where we're pessimistic and
I will do the pessimism time we'll do
the optimism okay why look at
constitutional law well when you write
down a constitution what you are doing
is drawing a blueprint for institutions
that are supposed to channel and manage
political conflict and they're supposed
to do that not just today but for the
foreseeable future they're supposed to
do that under sunder conditions of
exogenous constraints and shop under new
geopolitical new economic new social
conditions right they are supposed to
provide the means to solve political
conflicts they're supposed to provide
the means to solve flaws in the original
constitutional document what this means
is that constitutions have to be
designed to meet a range of political
not just one kind of political risks but
a wide variety of them come at
institutions in many different ways and
that can derail institutions in many
different ways an implication of that is
that when you design a constitution you
have to make trade-offs between
different kinds of risk management and
so in thinking about the ways the
Constitution addresses the problem of
backsliding risk one has to think about
it in relation to and in in terms of
trade-offs with other kinds of risk
management so here's an example
emergency powers are often thought after
cert instrument for democratic
backsliding the Constitution addresses
emergency powers by basically saying
nothing about them rather emergencies in
the American context are dealt through
aggressive and ambitious readings if
ambiguous statutory texts me an awful
lot of vague statutory text Texas on the
book and creative exploitation of very
very abstract constitutional provisions
this means that presidents have an awful
lot of leeway when it comes to
emergencies which means they can
impractical ate many Liberty privacy and
bodily integrity and trusts but it's
very difficult for them to say this is
an emergency so severe that I must break
the chain of democratic continuity so
our Constitution by by taking a response
to emergencies that involve silence
accentuates the risk of individual
rights violations but it buys a measure
of safety for democracy that's an
example of the kind of trade offs that
constitutions make all the time and it's
important to remember that constitutions
including ours are almost always written
under circumstances of great strength
limited time limited attention the
threat of civil war or violence lose on
horizon
right constitutions are are not only
have to make trade-offs but those
trade-offs are going to be imperfect
they're not going to be optimal our own
Constitution right if you're if you're
going to be pessimistic about
constitutions in general we you should
be really pessimistic about our
Constitution
why our constitution is the oldest still
operative organic document it is 231
years old 230 years old sorry it is a
hundred years older than the white part
it is 51 years older than the telegram
it is roughly contemporaneous to James
Watts steam engine
it is a quill in an age of smart book
styluses there is no reason to think
that it is well adapted to the
particular forms of risk that present to
constitutional democracies today so let
me be more specific about that in our
article my book we we argue that there
are basically two kinds of backsliding
fast slow we think that fast backsliding
has more or less not completely gone
away but the risk is has has diminished
over time we think that the risk of slow
back sightings of an erosion of
democracy is a substantial and we think
that there are five mechanisms through
which happens the Constitution does
reasonably well on one of five and
pretty much flunked on the other four so
let's start with the one on which it it
does reasonably well on this is the
question of amendment in Hungary as
we've heard and many other jurisdictions
would be autocrats autocrats or
competitive autocrats have changed the
text of the constitution as a way of
limiting political competition and
eroding competing institutional checks
our Constitution Article five has one of
the most difficult to navigate Amendment
mechanisms in the world today this means
that it is very hard for an or ban for
for a president here to do what orbán
did in Hungary changed the text of the
Constitution to content himself or his
party on the other hand it also means
that there's no real way to clarify that
the pardon power doesn't include a power
to pardon yourself there's no real way
to clarify that there is no
constitutional right to assert to an
automatic assault weapon or to a bomb
stock right so for all the good that
comes from article 5
in terms of mitigating backsliding risk
there's an awful lot of other stuff that
we live or die with second institutional
check or second constant pathway
concerns checks and balances and the
role played in particular by the
legislature and by the courts in
limiting presidential aggrandizement and
it was a patient of democracy in the
u.s. system a president acting with
authoritarian impulses when backed by a
aligned partisan aligned Congress has
very few legal limits on the ability or
faces very few legal constraints on his
or her ability to dismantle either
legislative constraints such as
congressional committee oversight or
judicial constraints it is often
forgotten the judicial independence and
the effective operation of the courts as
a check upon presidential authority is
not necessarily a matter of
constitutional text it is a matter of
pressing there is nothing in the
Constitution that says that a president
has to obey a federal court order and
there is a live academic debate in the
law schools about when and how an order
has to be obeyed by the president I
disagree here a little bit with Daniels
iblis terrific comments earlier today
insofar as I think that to the extent
that the separation of powers fails this
failure is a very old one Madison
initially imagined the branches as
acting on the basis of institutional
loyalties he imagined them engaging in
this kind of tooth and claw conflict
which through some unstated invisible
hand mechanism would lead to constrain
government but within the first 10 years
of the Constitution's operation Madison
along with Jefferson and Adams had built
the first party system a party system
that meant that partisan motivations
overcame quickly institutional loyalties
okay very quickly the the three last
measures many other constitutions
contain intra branch as well as inter
branch checks they contain institutions
like civil service protections like
Albert's murder or Inspector General's
hour comes our legal system has those
institutions we've seen for example the
office of governmental a X being very
effective the Congressional Budget
Office in some way and being very
effective but none of them are
constitutionalized none of those
protections of the integrity of the
bureaucratic rule of law are embedded in
our Constitution hence we've already
seen proposals to over to repeal the
Hatch Act we've seen a return to the
Hulman rule which which allows
congressional majorities to zero our
particular let bureaucrats our salaries
fourth pathway the deconstruction of the
public sphere
now many Americans if you ask them would
say we have a robust First Amendment and
it's certainly true the First Amendment
protects against the aggressive use of
libel law in the way that we've seen in
places like turkey in Roe on the other
hand the First Amendment conceptualizes
the threat to Democrat the Democratic
public sphere as purely a matter of
prohibitions that the government imposes
upon speech when it comes to for example
the government's effort to regulate
let's say fake speech or false news
excuse me or to curate your journalistic
ethics the Constitution to firms will be
stands in the way of such efforts and
the Constitution has nothing to say
about when and how the government does
or does not speak the Constitution has
nothing to say about intimidatory
government speech it has nothing to say
about false government speech it has
nothing to say about the obligation of
governments to disclose certain
information to the contrary to the
extent that we have a jurisprudence on
that point it is a jurisprudence which
favors governmental exclusion the final
point concerns partisan competition and
the quality and the preservation of that
possible competition whereas other
countries have special courts that are
devoted to the protection or the
adjudication of election out disputed
elections whereas other countries have
dedicated insulated election management
bodies what does the Constitution do
article 1 section 4 delegates to the
States
hence we have North Carolina hence we
have
ramshackle uneven haphazard system of
electoral administration that is as we
have found out intensely vulnerable to
foreign relations hacking so along four
out of five metrics we think the
Constitution supplies very little
protection against the means of
democratic backsliding that are observed
in other jurisdictions so given the
right pots given the right political
conjunction such backsliding is is not
just possible it's eminently legal
great so that was the bad news so what
did the following people have in common
Rand Paul al sharpton the Koch brothers
retired Justice John Paul Stevens and
Fox News commentator Marty Levin anyone
know they've all called at one time or
another for an article five convention
here in the United States and for those
who don't know we all learned in civics
about the way the Constitution's
amendment two-thirds of of each house of
Congress three-quarters of the states
there is an alternative never used
mechanism which is that two-thirds of
state legislators can call on Congress
to call a new constitutional convention
in 2014
Michigan became the 34th state to issue
some such call no convention as yet
issued there's issues about counting
some of these calls are restricted to
something like a balanced budget
amendment or on the left side on the
sort of democratic side Rhode Island's
is limited to talking about overturning
Citizens United campaign finance so you
have different calls for different
things and there's lots of legal
questions of course because the
Constitution is 230 years old ambiguous
and none of these issues have ever been
decided can a convention be limited
avi or may not know there are of course
in 1787 in Philadelphia was supposed to
be a limited convention to amend the
Articles of Confederation and became a
runaway convention and it's actually for
this reason that I myself I'm very
skeptical that much good would come of
this of this effort and so I'm not a big
supporter but I guess the question one
has to ask is suppose it happens what
should we do or more generally what
would a new country just emerging on the
stage that is concerned with this issue
of constitutional and democratic erosion
what kind of institutions should they
choose and you know it's kind of
insanely intensely Madisonian
proposition actually the founding
fathers were dedicated empiricists and
when they were writing their product
that we so celebrate they went out and
looked
over the world they sort of tried to
absorb all available knowledge and so in
some sense you can imagine you know
James Madison and Al Sharpton and you
know Rand Paul and all those guys too
sitting in a room what would they come
up with so here I think what they would
do is they look around right and so
they've been by my count to work on
something called the comparative
constitutions project 800 or 900 new
constitutions written for all the
different countries in that time and the
modal one drawn today looks very little
like that of the United States
lots of technological developments have
happened it's not the quill anymore
right it's the stylus and thus there are
things to learn from these other
countries so I'm just gonna go through a
few of the institutions what are the
things we are lacking if we were to
start over well one that Aziz mentioned
in passing is of course neutral
institutions to run elections something
like 45% of national constitutions have
an electoral commission that's
constitutionally protected it's formed
in an independent manner and actually 13
American states have similar kinds of
commissions to draw the boundaries now
for reasons he mentioned you and there's
constitutional restrictions on adopting
a national you know statute to make
every state do that but that seems like
something that would be good to do in
the United States we know that those
states that have those neutral electors
you Electoral Commission's have more
competitive elections more responsive
policies to the electorate that's been
shown by political scientists and so
that seems like something we would
seriously consider a second important
category of things is institutions of
horizontal accountability right so the
average Constitution drawn today will
have three or four other constitutional
institutions that are produced
independently that are that are
protected from political manipulation
that do particular tasks a human rights
commission a counter corruption
Commission Ombudsman you know in South
Africa these are called chapter 9
institutions there's a whole bunch of
them listed in Chapter 9 of the
Constitution one of them the Public
Protector is the institution which
issued the report on Jacob Zuma spending
all that money on his house and you know
South Africa's a kind of backsliding
democracy I think would be a charitable
way to put it but zoo may have to pay
back that money so even in that kind of
context a one-party state more or less
with a powerful charismatic guy you know
you're able to have some accountability
and so I think that's a set of
institutions we'd consider one way to
think about is that the more
institutions the harder it is for a
single party to take them all over so
there's more likely to be some
institution to sort of blow the you know
pull the fire alarm and inform the
public about malfeasance protecting the
civil service another thing we see in
many constitutions civil service
Commission's explicit statements about
the state itself and you know this is
something we completely lack is disease
has catalogued and something that I
think we would certainly consider and
you know there's may be some statutory
improvements that we could do even short
of constitutional amendment you know
there trend around the world is one that
I think we were really at the forefront
of its what's called judicialization the
transfer of policy decisions from
legislatures from the executive branch
towards courts and it's you know been a
massive development and trend in both
democracies and autocracies over the
last couple of decades and you know
something that I certainly celebrated at
one time we thought well the judges are
independent they were sort of
constrained by professional norms that's
a good thing of course you know that
anytime you have an institution which is
powerful in invites capture and that's
exactly what we heard this morning has
happened in Poland and Hungary it's the
first institution that you go after if
you are trying to erode your democracy
as the courts the monitors and so that
may you know suggest that courts are
certainly no panacea and ought to be
designed very carefully now but in the
United States we we face this problem
right the stakes of this unprecedented
escalation and judicial appointments and
such the end of the filibuster you know
this is because the stakes are so hot
with a Supreme Court justice and you
know a reform that many have talked
about including justice Stevens is
reducing the the term from a life term
to something like
eighteen years or fourteen years you can
come up with a number and that would of
course put us more squarely in the in
the mainstream of other constitutions
there's no other country that has true
life terms for Supreme Court or
Constitutional Court justices so that's
certainly something I think we could
learn from restoring the supermajority
to the appointments process and this is
one of these things where it's hard to
see how it would happen that would be
incentive compatible given that we've
escalated it's precisely what Daniel was
talking about this morning you know that
once you have an escalation it's very
hard to back off but it would be
something to be worth restoring
to other things protecting the public
sphere as Suzy says as said you know we
do we lack the ability and that's a good
thing to to regulate many of the media
and such although one thing I think is
particularly important is and for other
countries maybe more than the United
States is the role of competition law
with regard to the media there are many
countries where there's you know one
dominant media company that's owned by
the president or something like that
Berlusconi was kind of a leader in this
regard and it's not uncommon so that
seems like something where you can you
could even in the United States you can
have vigorous antitrust enforcement
without I without a or antitrust
scrutiny without actually violating the
First Amendment let's see the other I
guess maybe I'll close with a comment
about regime type because it did come up
this morning the discussion about so
you're a new country you're worried
about retrogression you have these big
choices to make shall we be presidential
she'll be parliamentary she would be
semi presidential Arturo Valenzuela
mentioned juan linz this morning so it's
worth revisiting this debate which he
you know pioneered
two decades ago I've done some
regressions on this and sort of a now
analyzed it and I have not been able to
figure I've not been able to come up
with results that suggest any one of
these regimes is more vulnerable to
retrogression um if you just think about
the cases that are on everyone's mind
Venezuela is presidential Hungary is
parliamentary Poland semi-presidential
there have also been near misses in each
regime type where the system is pulled
back from what appeared to be in a roach
Sri Lanka
important case where intra-party
disputing and inter-party competition
was what saved Sri Lanka from being
governed by Rajapaksa for life and so
there's you know in my view what we
ought to be doing is thinking not so
much about these grand regime types but
about mechanisms within executive
legislative relations that sort of are
beneficial and the one we talk about a
lot in our book is opposition rights so
many constitutional schemes the
opposition will have a right to chair
certain committees in Parliament the for
example this scrutiny committee or the
budget and you know budget oversight and
suspending well that's something that
could be done actually by congressional
rule here in the United States it's
within our grasp to do things like that
if we can simply organize the politics
and of course that's not simple at all
um I'm just gonna close with one comment
which is all of these institutional does
I say anyone who studies institutions
you know knows that you know there's no
panacea right institutions do not
produce outcomes but they do shift
incentives and access nudges and can act
as roadblocks in this case with regard
to erosion there is always the risk that
if you're designing for one thing you're
gonna exacerbate some other risk so a
constitutional designed to prevent
Democratic erosion might produce more
gridlock and less you know vigorous
government but to us that seems to be a
something worth considering at this
particular moment in our history thanks
[Applause]
I just want to start by saying that not
many students of American politics have
ever seriously considered threats to the
durability of American governing
institutions American is attended to
worry a lot more about the tendencies
towards gridlock and uncover nobility
than problems of tending towards
autocracy but recent US politics has
been enough to unsettle even the most
complacent among us and comparative work
on democratization certainly shows that
one cannot take the durability of
democratic institutions for granted
Nancy burr Mayo identifies three
varieties of backsliding that have
emerged as common pathways to democratic
breakdown since the end of the Civil War
I mean into the Cold War sorry
promissory coup executive aggrandizement
and strategic election manipulation
promissory coup is highly unlikely in
the United States firm and long-standing
civilian control the military closes off
this pathway the more serious questions
about possible Democratic backsliding in
the United States focus instead on
executive aggrandize m't and strategic
election manipulation executive
aggrandizement occurs when elected
executives we can checks on executive
power there's no question that the US
presidency has grown in power along with
the rise of the administrative and
national security state party
polarization has also amplified
presidential power in some respects
Congress is mired in partisan gridlock
are less able to assert themselves
legislatively allowing presidents to
make more use of their unilateral powers
but just as the US presidency has grown
in power so too has the power of the
president's opponents party polarization
means that presidents confront a more
tightly organized opposition party in
Congress and throughout the federal
system most of the time the president's
party opposition controls Congress u.s.
national government has been divided
seventeen seventy five percent of the
time since 1980 but even unified
government does not guarantee a
president will get his way with Congress
the means by which members of Congress
are elected makes congressional parties
far less hierarchical than parliamentary
parties the federal system also usually
operates so that presidents face a
substantial number of states controlled
by their party opposition state
governments have numerous tools to block
or dilute national policies because
state cooperation is usually needed for
implementation in countries where
executive aggrandize Minh has occurred
has often preceded via democratic means
to national elections referenda
legitimate lawmaking processes there's
little prospect for strengthening the
American presidency via these pathways
it's hard to imagine a President of the
United States garnering the kind of
support that would be required to make
major institutional changes the barriers
to constitutional amendment in the u.s.
are obviously extraordinarily high but
even regular legislation rarely precedes
by simple majority very little
legislation passes on narrow party lines
this figure shows the average percentage
of minority party members voting in
support of the legislation that
successfully passes the Senate the day
to start with the 93rd Congress of
1973-74 and moved through to 2013 2014
you can see that the average rarely dips
below 50% meaning that most legislation
including most of Mayhew's landmark laws
Garner's majority support from both
parties the same is also true in the
house even in the polarized era very
little legislation passes Congress on
party line votes there's no trend
towards more legislation passing by
party line votes presidents can rarely
command the kind of broad political
support they would need to assemble
super majorities to enhance their powers
all the recent presidents have one
office by slim margins by historical
standards this figure shows the winning
presidential candidates share of the
electoral college there has not been a
landslide presidential election in
American politics since 1984 when Ronald
Reagan won a national majority of fifty
eight point eight percent for the past
decade presidents have spent much of
their terms near or below fifty percent
approval in public opinion polls the
difficulties of consolidating national
power and US politics have been on clear
display since the 2016 elections
President Trump has been impeded at
every turn despite unified control nine
months into his term of office no major
legislation has
passed a large share of executive
offices remain unfilled federal courts
have blocked or limited major executive
orders unified party control has not
spared the president a serious
bipartisan investigation of Russian
intervention in the elections nor the
appointment of a special counsel to
investigate the matter a president in
his first year in office is usually at
the peak of his power as with most
presidents Trump's political capital
will almost certainly decline over time
Republicans are virtually assured of
seat losses in the 2018 midterm
elections that will further reduce the
president's leverage a second form of
democratic backsliding strategic
election manipulation denotes a range of
actions aimed at tilting the electoral
playing field in favor of incumbents the
United States electoral law and
procedures are hardly free of this kind
of deck stacking the political interests
of incumbents and majority parties
unquestionably shape rules regarding
voter registration ballot access
campaign finance legislative districting
and government ethics strategic election
manipulation poses a reduced threat at
the federal level however simply because
national power over elections is so
limited voting procedures and voter
registration legislative districting and
ballot access are all almost entirely
regulated at the state and local levels
in states where one party is dominant
the majority party may adopt rules that
are favorable to its interests but
majority party's strength varies
considerably across states parties can
use this kind of deck stacking in states
where they are already strong but they
have difficulty doing so in swing states
are states that lean towards the
opposing party it's not to say it's
impossible as the Wisconsin example
illustrates but the state-by-state
nature of these institutional battles
limits opportunities for a national
party to insulate itself from electoral
tides and it frustrates efforts at
election manipulation at the federal
level
if we define populism as onion on a DB
does as an anti elite movement that
expresses the general will of an organic
and wholesome people then I would rate
populism as a more serious threat to
American liberal democracy than any
slide towards autocracy scholars of
American public opinion have long known
that the values under girding liberal
democracy are fragile at the grassroots
Americans are often unwilling to apply
the abstract civil libertarian
principles they espouse to specific
unpopular or threatening groups
authoritarian and ethnocentric beliefs
are important drivers of public opinion
long before the anti-establishment
fervor of the 2016 elections Hibbing
entice morris wrote two books
documenting the extent to which
Americans embrace populist notions of an
organic and wholesome people in Contra
distinction to an out-of-touch political
elite in the data they report majorities
of respondents exhibit little
understanding of the sources of conflict
in Congress and impatience with debate
and deliberation frustrated with the
contentiousness of real-world democracy
they report surprising percentages of
people respond favorably to the mention
of decision-making structures that are
not democratic such as turning
government over to successful
businesspeople america's longstanding
openness to populism becomes more
troubling for liberal democracy during a
time when the party system is becoming
increasingly racialized even as early as
1989 Huck Feld and Co Felton Cofield
wrote a book about how race was driving
out class as the most significant factor
in electoral politics since 1989 the
American electorate has become more
racially and ethnically diverse and the
diversity gap between the parties has
grown progressively wider the data
displayed here from a 20-17 Pew Research
Center report shows demographic change
in the parties between 1992 and 2016 as
you can see the Democratic Party is
becoming more diverse at a faster rate
than the country as a whole
while Republicans are becoming more
diverse at a slower rate
recent work by Michael tesslar has shown
that white voters attitudes towards race
have become a stronger predictor of
their partisan attachments these racial
differences between the parties are
starkly reflected in Congress where
minorities make up bullying 39% of
Democratic members but only 5.5 percent
of Republican members a racialized party
system in an electorate with
questionable commitment to liberal
values is a troubling development it's
not easy to manage racial tensions in a
democracy in any case much less win race
becomes a principal line of political
cleavage Americans who would respond
favorably to a more racialized populist
form of politics may be an underserved
constituency political elites are the
traditional bulwark of liberal democracy
in that vein mainstream politicians have
tended to steer clear of explicitly
racial appeals but the gap between
regular voters and the political elite
on this dimension can present
opportunities for ambitious politicians
particularly in times of low trust in
government should politicians activate
such cleavages there's no guarantee that
party gatekeepers can stop such
candidates from winning nominations or
taking control of the party just as
Republicans could not stop the
nomination of Trump nor more recently
the Senate nomination of Roy Moore the
2016 elections suggest a future a
possible future in which American
democracy might become more populist and
raised less racially inclusive over the
course of his campaign Trump violated
the norms of liberal democracy in
numerous ways in violating these norms
Trump was able to offer primary voters a
product that other Republican elites
refused to supply giving voice to such
sentiments may have allowed him to forge
a unique bond of trust and authenticity
with the party base it seems almost
certain that trumps future Trump's
example will point the way to other
ambitious politicians seeking
advancement in the future so as we take
stock of the prospects for democratic
backsliding in the United States the
more serious vulnerabilities Center on
liberal democratic
Norm's rather than on executive
aggrandize meant or election
manipulation whatever its failings in
other respects the Madisonian system
thwarts concentration of power but
populism a Minds mindset with deep roots
in American public opinion threatens the
norms of multi-ethnic liberal democracy
in the United States as it does
elsewhere
[Applause]
thank you very much David from they
wisely opened by making himself popular
by telling some very good jokes in order
to create a space to then make himself
unpopular by challenging the audience
we've used probably a lot of people
didn't agree with um I want to do the
inverse of that which is where I'm gonna
unwisely start by making myself
unpopular and then hopefully try and
butter you up at the end so this session
is called can it happen here and what
can we do about it and one of my sort
things I noticed you know Freud was this
really great conference is that this is
sort of always how these things tend to
go I've been to a lot of these things
over the past year none as eminent and
erudite is vist but bill there's always
sort of a bit at the end which is like
okay and perhaps we should sort of kind
of think about what to do about it and I
think that that's a shame that it
shouldn't be half of the last panel and
that you know we're stepping outside of
our comfort zone in general I think as
scholars by taking on more public work
as a lot of people in this room have of
a course of last year and so on but I
think we should step out of our comfort
zone that one step further by taking
seriously our task not just to give a
diagnosis of what's happening but to
actually apply our expertise and our
academic knowledge to figuring out what
to do about in a serious way and not as
an afterthought so I'm gonna try and do
a little bit of that in eight minutes
but but I feel like that is a
conversation we now have a really rich
robust conversation about what's going
on and I don't think we have
the same rich robust colonization about
what to do so I think my suggestions
will might end up being a little
amateurish but I think that's because we
need to have more of a real academic you
found a debate in that area so that's
sort of my challenge to start off with
um okay so to know what we can do about
it we do have to intend a little bit
about whether it can happen here and
what's going on very briefly I think
there's three basic scenarios of what
Trump is going to do to the American
Republic
I think we've spent a lot of time
talking about the first one which is how
likely it is who is not with Trump sort
of outright destroys it right and I
think that we are nearly approaching
insofar as that's possible at a
conference of sort of you know 23
excellent speakers we actually soared up
in a broad space of agreement on that I
have the impression which is to say that
yes there are things that can will be
dangerous to be American Republic we
shouldn't be complacent the Constitution
is not somehow inviolable and and magic
but it doesn't look as for Donald Trump
is about to destroy it sort of tomorrow
right um that's partially frankly
because he he's not as strategic as some
other foreign populace but we've seen
rise in other countries he doesn't quite
seem to have the political discipline or
perhaps political skill and acumen of a
Viktor Orban or of a coach in ski I also
agree with that assessment I don't think
it looks like Krampus is strong and
Moxie but I just want to sound one
important note of caution which is that
most scholars of Russia didn't really
think that bloody me Putin was kind of
completely destroy a democratic system
there a lot of scholars of Turkey fought
two or three or four years into Russia
Padawans rule but things were going fine
scholars we're little worried about aa
button but at the beginning they didn't
think that he was destroying democracy
in Hungary and even most scholars of
Poland further very worried about the
peace victory in 2015 we're quite
insistent that democracy was going to be
able to defend itself so you know we're
less than a year into a trump presidency
and our track record isn't great at
predicting those things now I still
think it doesn't look like is this
drawing
see but I think we should at least keep
in our mind the fact that we've been
wrong about similar kinds of things in
other countries okay so what's the
second scenario the second scenario is a
super optimistic scenario right Trump is
about to fail he got impeached or he'll
resign or he'll just Lewis disasters in
2020 and there'll be a sort of moment of
coming together we'll realize that this
is all terrible nightmare
people who I've been writing about who
are sort of disengaged from democracy a
little critical of it realized but it's
important to live in a democracy but you
don't want to have a strongman leader
and everything will be great we haven't
talked much about that scenario today I
think mostly because people think it's
self-evident Lee out of the hounds I
don't see the making so that right I
mean the the the degree of partisanship
we now have a degree of anger we have at
our politics and a degree of long-term
structural drivers of a rise of populism
we have a broad enough and deep enough
that it doesn't look like we're gonna
have that kumbaya moment even if Trump
wins Timucua Rand for example had some
very interesting remarks about what
would actually happen I'm sure Wars kids
well what would actually happen if Trump
lost it's not obvious but we would then
be out of words so that leaves the third
kind of possibility and it's a
possibility but it's been haunting me
for the last months I call it the sort
of ancient Rome scenario there's have a
historical metaphors for it right but
when you think of Trump not as some of
his favorite presidents like Jackson but
if you think of him as something like
the kuraki a moment of norm disruption a
moment of real conflict between an elite
and people who sort of want to overthrow
it and it starts to break down some
norms and so on you managed to get
relatively mainstream politicians back
into power for a little bit but the
actual underlying drivers of this
haven't gone away and so over a course
of 50 or 60 years who keep having
similar movements come back to power
come back to power and eventually
they've really managed to erode the
institutions and the norms sufficiently
for a system to break down I think that
to me what keeps me up at night at this
point
is that scenario okay so what can we do
in order to stop that scenario well
first of all we have to recognize so
that scenario is being driven by some
deep structural factors right I'm in an
ancient Rome this is a question of land
reform and some real economic and social
transformations that ancient Roman
Republic had trouble dealing with and I
think we have a similar set of things
here in very brief it seems to me the
best three big transformations better
going on three ways in which the
stability of democracy in the past
cannot predict stability now because the
circumstances have changed because we
don't live in the same world as 50 years
ago so the first two versus economic
from 1945 to 1960 were living standard
to the average American doubles from
1960 to 1980 five doubles again since
1985 it's been flat but radically
transforms how people think about
politics they used to never particularly
laugh politicians particularly trust
politicians but it give them benefit of
doubt and now they're saying I'm not
getting anything out of this let's throw
some [ __ ] against four and see what
sticks the second thing and I agree with
people who were pointing out at least an
odd rival that the world is not moral
causal it's about race and ethnicity
right this is something that's very
obvious in Western Europe rise of
populist movements where you had these
DP mono-ethnic in monocultural countries
which had a very exclusionary
understanding of what real poll real
Hungarian real German a real Swedish and
they're slowly starting to transform
versus you have mass immigration in the
United States we've always had a
multi-ethnic society but one with a
strict racial hierarchy and we're slowly
starting to overcome that and again it
is the case that some people welcome
that and embrace that I think a lot of
people in this room do but some people
are very resentful to that and that is
one of the deeper driver service and the
third thing that underlines all of this
and gives it additional force and
ditional by it is the arrival of social
media and new technologies which I think
we should understand as closing the gap
between political and financial and
economic elites and the rest of society
that's great no foreign regimes gives us
a lot of ability for the mccr attic
movements to oppose them but it can be
dangerous in democratic regimes it does
overcome some real problems but it means
that it's much easier for fake news for
hate speech and so on to spread and so
what we're facing is this mix of these
free effects okay so what can we do
about vers effects well the first thing
to do by the way is simply to get
involved in politics and to encourage
other people to get involved in politics
one thing we've learned from a lot of
the countries we've been talking about
today is that when you manage to be a
populist at the polls they don't have a
chance to a road for Constitution and
even once van government if you beat
them at the first opportunity you have
you probably retain a sort of a chance
to do it but the longer they on power
the more they can erode the system and
the less even the playing field becomes
so actually getting involved in politics
and getting engaged in part is one
obvious thing but all of us in this room
can do that we can under our other
people to do okay it also needs to be
some more policy responses some more
structural things in my mind it's clear
that if the economic trends over the
last 30 years go on for the next 50
democracies toast
Adam Przewalski's was reflecting a very
interesting way on his own research and
his famous papers from from from a 1990s
and saying well perhaps the present is
not like the past I think there's a real
question about whether what you need is
$14,000 GDP per capita in order to be
stable which was you know as in Tina and
the 70s and so on or whatever what you
need is an ongoing improvement in living
standards we don't have any historical
precedent for a democracy that doesn't
experience improvements in living
standards and is stable for decades on
end so I think we need to think
seriously about a set of economic
policies that embrace the globalization
and the benefits have come from if it
embraces free marginal benefits will
come from it but that take seriously the
task of giving average citizens hope for
the future and improving the living
standards the second thing is about
identity
and I think it's really important for us
to fight for a vision of a multi-ethnic
society and I think that involves
actually a dual fight it obviously
involves a fight against the white
nationalism of a right and some of its
enablers who are now sitting in the
White House um but I think it also
involves us putting forward a notion and
here's my old procopius in me speaking
perhaps a notion of what it can be for
us to actually build a multi-ethnic
society together and for us to see what
we have in common across racial and
religious lines rather than just what
divides us I think at this point is very
tempting for us to only speak about
injustice and discrimination and we
obviously have to address those things
and obviously have to fight against
those things but I think we also have to
offer a vision for what it would like
look like for us to have something in
common and to fight for those ideals and
to domesticate nationalism rather than
leaving the field of nationalism to the
right to be exploited by white
nationalists I think we have to build an
inclusive patriotism but can occupy that
space
I think of nationalism as a half
domesticated animal and it's always
going to remain dangerous but we have to
do our best to domesticate it because
I've always be other guys are gonna go
and exploit it and turn it into a Raging
Bull the third thing is about social
media now there's some things we can do
in terms of persuading Facebook and
Twitter to change my algorithms there
may be some things we can do legally
further it's obviously very difficult
United States because the First
Amendment nothing that's by and large a
good thing but what we can do if we can
do so much about the supply side of
hateful ideas on the Internet we can
take much more seriously our obligation
to influence the demand side and one of
the things this means is to fight in a
proud way for the ideals of liberal
democracy we have this huge glaring
promise all of today that liberal
democracy is a good thing but it's worth
defending but has framed every
intervention though we rarely
cover Sphinx and we rarely think about
those things by the way in our teaching
when you think about the number of
people that were people in this room
reach I'm an I'm of people that the
people in verse four the people who the
people in this room reach reach
it is a vast number of people and I
think means to challenge ourselves and
we have a hat that we wear as scholars
which is to say as teachers how we can
once again live up to the ideals of our
founding fathers I say as a new American
citizen and by the way every political
thinker from Plato to Aristotle and from
Machiavelli to Rousseau of turning
children into citizens of turning the
next generation into people who actually
defend the political institutions that
is not how we think of our job as
academics and frankly I think it should
be now I said that I would try and
butter up the audience and the
organizers at the end I think we have
come a long way in the last year I think
academia has become a less quietest
place I think political scientists have
started to understand but we have civic
obligations but and rival to our duties
as scholars they are coterminous or
there's a Venn diagram or something like
that but they're not rival with each
other and I really do think that both
this conference is a great sign of that
and writeline watch it's a great
testament to that so so I think we can
pat ourselves on the back for a little
bit and we can certainly applaud the
organizers of this conference for a
moment but but we also need to take
seriously where we're still falling
short and where there's still more
things we can do to actually try and
defend our institutions thank you
[Applause]
so thank you one and all
what we're going to be doing now for the
next 35 minutes is we're going to start
I'm going to have a question for the
panel and while I'm doing that we're
going to be collecting up written
questions for the panel and I will pick
on them with a strong bias towards
legibility so so but so while that's
going on you're gonna get pick up there
somebody picking up the questions I've
got some yeah yeah okay so I I've found
all of the presentations
thought-provoking and I wanted to start
with start from the the observation that
David and Josh are both made explicitly
but was implicit in the comments of many
other people that before talking about
backsliding and ways of stopping
backsliding we should think about what's
producing the phenomenon in the first
place because otherwise the the
solutions might not be getting to the
problem and as I listen to the various
speakers a number of them had things to
say about that Julia was talking about
disrupting the racial order as an
underlying phenomenon David himself was
talking about migration as threatening
people and precipitating a lot of the
politics we've seen Aziz and Tom focused
on an obsolete Constitution and Francis
focused on populism particularly
populism that incorporates race and
racism and yasha focused on economic
stagnation racial racial integration
multiculturalism and all that and
and social media and I I think there's a
lot to be said about a lot of those
things but it seems to me that there is
kind of elephant in the room that's not
being talked about that somewhat touched
on by Yeshua's talk about economic
stagnation but I want to really push
push the panelists a little further to
stitute it's what's what's really behind
that and how might we think about
political reforms that can address
what's really driving this problem and I
think I think that the way I would eye
my path into this and this is what I'm
going to throw out to the panelists to
comment on that really it's not the
absence of upward mobility or
improvement it's it's a bleaker thing
that that I think we know from from
Kahneman and Tversky and others that
experiencing losses or the fear of loss
is a much more potent motivator of
people than foregone gains and I think
that loss and fear of loss can trump
just about anything in politics and I
think that that's a very important thing
to think about and what I'm thinking
here again is thinking here about is
just think about make America great
again in some in a con event first he
says he's a brilliant slogan because it
it right there communicates something
has been taken away from you and I'm
gonna bring it back as opposed to
America's best days are ahead or
something like that it is focuses it's a
framing effect that focuses people's
attention on something that they have
lost and I think that the real issue is
is wage stagnation
real wage declines for many of the
people who have been mobilized to
support Trump so I think everybody
should read for instance and I apologize
if this was brought up earlier while I
was doing my day job but
three books everybody should read one is
early host shield strangers in their own
land an ethnographic study of Tea Party
people in Louisiana that was done over
five years before Trump came along and
she added a chapter about Trump at the
end Kramer
Catherine I think it is Kramer politics
of resentment a book about Wisconsin
again
white working-class rural Wisconsin
again a five-year ethnographic study of
the politics of resentment based on
disappearing jobs collapsing communities
the anticipation that it's only going to
get worse into the future and then for
an order by a graph like a graphical
account of the same thing
JD Vance's hillbilly elegy which is
about in Tennessee and Ohio again an
account of devastated communities jobs
having completely disappeared massive
drug addiction through all generations
collapsing families you know and you
read these three books and you
understand why the Democrats focus on
things like transgender bathrooms
alienated these these people so I think
that what's driving this of course is
the disappearance of employment and
certainly the disappearance of
employment that was was reasonably well
paid by the standards with which these
people expected had been living and
we're expecting to live into the future
and the disappointment and disappearance
of employment security so even the
people who have jobs have few
expectations of keeping them for very
long or at least keeping them at the
same wages for very long and so it so it
seems to me that unless a political
system can find a way to address
that it's very unlikely that changing
the Constitution in one in in in various
ways or focusing on the other things
that people have brought up that are no
doubt important but it doesn't seem to
me that we are we going to get very far
so what I would ask the panelists who to
speak to is to the extent that the this
is the underlying problem that's
generating the kind of politics that
we're seeing what it what are the
failures in the political system that
are hampering the capacity to address
that and what can we do about that so I
will collect up questions so I've been
thinking a lot about this and you
described a substantial portion of my
syllabus in your book recommendation so
I've been thinking a lot about this and
um and I I don't really want to answer
so much as I want to push back on this
with recognition that everything you
know about democratic theory I learned
from someone in this room in sue Stokes
I see Brian Garston back there um and
but now I'm gonna push back so I think
if if the underlying cause of this were
economics and we would have seen Trump
win the presidency in 2008 and I think
if we look at US history this is what
was so stunning to me about the
realization about racial orders we don't
see these legitimacy challenges come up
so much in response to serious recession
there were some during the Great
Depression we see them in response to
race and I think that's underlying the
inability of the political system to
address the the economic problems that
you described so if we were to entertain
your premise for a moment that that is
what's driving particularly we're
talking about Trump right we're talking
about Trump if if economic stagnation
and lack of mobility is driving the
Trump movement
we if we accept that premise for a
moment then the question becomes why why
isn't there a political movement that
unites different people who are facing
these economic challenges and the answer
is there's there's not and so I think
that that's I guess I'm sort of pushing
back to say I think that still the
problem-solving mechanism the not there
is racial and then the solution is
economic and so that's the logic of the
problem and now David's gonna tell me
why I'm wrong I think look obviously
economic stagnation income income
stagnation is a very important part of
where these movements come from but I
will note that the second best
performing the entire developed world
the country with the second best
performance after Canada or its middle
class is Germany if you look at quintile
zabinga
the German middle quintile has done
better than anybody's except Canada and
we've ever seen a collapse of the German
parties in the center and the rise of
German parties of the extremist right
and left in the wake of the biggest
migration shock in German history
probably you can cope with a lot of
migration if your economies are doing
great and probably if your economies are
not doing so great especially middle
income people are not good and you have
and you restrict her immigration you can
buy some stability it's the combination
I agree with Josh although I've been
fine with his three factors it is
economic stagnation for middle income
people the increasing levels of ethnic
diversity so there's less social trust
and I would say instead of social media
I point to the aging of the baby boom
generation which means that you have
rising claims on resources public and
private at the same time as you have
fewer resources to go around and less
willingness to share because of an
increasingly diverse population
basically I see what would what
political elites have been doing since
about 2000 is applying a series of pain
tests to their population how much pain
can we administer before you do
something when take away your money
we're in a chain we're going to raise
questions about the reliability of your
pensions in health care and we're going
to change your countries in ways you
were never consulted about and
not gonna like and that we're gonna call
you names about if you objective Francis
I just want to say you know as we
reflect on what we can learn from the
2016 elections is that it was a very
normal election that the demographic
groups that supported Republican parties
or supported Trump were the same
demographic groups that supported Romney
the demographic groups that supported
Hillary Clinton were this were the same
ones that supported Barack Obama that 90
percent of self-identified Democrats
supported Clinton 90 percent of
self-identified Republicans supported
Trump that as odd as Trump is in terms
of you know his platform and what he was
offering the behavior of the American
electorate was as if this was an
entirely normal election now we've paid
a great deal of attention to that small
but decisive increment of the vote that
was key to Trump's victory that mainly
the Rust Belt vote that was responsive
to the make America great message that
liked he's his deviation from Republican
orthodoxy on trade and immigration but
the outcome of this election was on a
knife's edge and that I I think we
shouldn't give undue weight even though
this this increment of the population
was important for the outcome of this
particular elections it's no reason to
conclude that that look that they will
similarly be decisive for future
elections that it's hard to predict what
our politics will look like but right
now for me the main thing that stands
out for the 2016 election is just the
extent to which our pre-existing
patterns that we've seen in presidential
elections for a long stretch of time
continue to hold
so so a few thoughts I'm the first is
but I'm a little skeptical about Colima
2016 election normal now I know that
there's some sort of very
straightforward and obvious evidence for
that right I mean the thing that you
didn't mention that but that is always
listed in that same breath is that you
know 97% of congressmen or something
like that could realized it and so on I
do wonder for whether if a candidate
like Donald Trump had somehow managed to
run on the Republican ticket in 1980 he
would have been able to keep so much of
a coalition right so it's true that the
Coalition on which she won was in many
ways a traditional Republican coalition
but the fact that she was able to win on
that coalition to me seems like a sign
of some very deep change and so I think
it's Abe it's possible to acknowledge
what points you just made and still
preserve the fortress is not a normal
election now I agree for with with what
a few things I mean one is that when you
think about how does Trump lose in 2020
and I think for anybody who cares about
a liberal democracy if it is something
but we have to care about and it's
estrangement say an academic conference
but I think but that's obvious from
everything we've talked about today it's
probably unwise to focus narrowly on the
80,000 voters that made Trump lose the
20 win the 2016 election and that's in
part because of the bigger demographic
shifts you see in our countries right I
mean the strongest party among non
immigrant workers in Germany now is not
the social democratic party it's not the
Christian Democratic parties we all turn
to for Germany the strongest party among
white workers in France for good while
now has been upon us you're not the
strongest party among white workers in
Austria as far out populist so I think
most likely it's a question of stemming
the bleeding in those groups of a
population while winning all the other
populations that sort of my little piece
of amateur campaign strategy which
nobody asked me to do that but to speak
to a larger question I think that a sort
of a couple of weird things in this
debate right the first is
this continual debate that is playing
out a really low intellectual level in
the public media but in an odd way we
are creating at a higher intellectual
level here of you know is it the economy
or is it race and and and and and and I
really do think that it's both now in
the economy it's not how wealthy are you
but it is a lot of measures about how
optimistic you are and how affluent the
region you are in is and how many high
qualified people that are there
how likely respective jobs get automated
right so it's slightly more
sophisticated measure which is obvious
to us in the case of immigration by the
way none of us say it can't be
immigration because people New York
don't vote for Trump right so that point
is obvious to us then some are not
obvious to us and in in in in in the
economy but but I was speaking to a
legislator and I think it really made
clear to me and he said look thirty
years ago when I ask people who are you
they said I'm a teamster right oh I'm a
foreman in the factory right they
identified by the job they identified by
the earned identity and as for all kinds
of complicated reasons a lot of them
have lost access to that aren't identity
you ask them now who they are and they
say well I'm white and I'm like those
people over there
right and so I think the the brew that
goes into a political anger that often
expresses itself in cultural and and and
racial some of racist terms can in part
be economic now the last thing I want to
say I've been hogging for a little bit
is is that there's a sort of weird
paradox to me in the public debate about
the cultural side of this and it's that
the same people who are most prone to
describing America as in essence in the
end a white nationalist nation right in
an essence really deeply marked by its
racism also tend to be the people whose
prescriptions essentially is to double
down on or to create a coalition of
minorities and that seems to me just
really bizarre because when you look at
the patterns and the us lecture that's
true that the minority may eventually be
the majority but that's not gonna be for
some thirty years even on the most
to Mystic scenarios right and so there's
something reproducible to me about this
but either but if so I thought you think
and I'm thinking through this in this
moment I've not quite been able to put
my finger on it but but either you think
that America is deeply racist and if you
want to make sure that the racist aren't
in charge then you have to actually make
a pitch and economic policy because
that's the only way that you can ever
win right all you have to think that no
most americans ah willing to be won over
by an inclusive vision of a nation but
also does something for them and I think
given if nothing else what the repor
forces in the electorate is that's what
we got to be we got to build a coalition
where we can talk about racial injustice
and and and overcome discrimination but
also think very seriously about how to
appeal to the people we need in order to
build a winning coalition and I see
surprisingly few people being in that
space because by ivor to the left of it
or to the right of it we haven't talked
too much at least in this panel about
voting and who votes and you know when
we talk about building coalitions that
matters a great deal um while it's true
that there are some overlap in the
populations of people who vote and don't
vote it's also true I think that um
people who don't vote tend to be more
interested in government intervention
and government spending on things like
health care and so you know in the kind
of frustration about you know
essentially the white working-class
right the three books you mentioned are
all about white people and people of
color in this country have also dealt
with you know lack of Economic
Opportunity of not gone in the same
political direction so we're talking
about you know white people feeling this
sense of loss and this sense of threat
and you know even in that population
there's a difference between people who
vote and don't vote and I'm not sure
what to offer about this because
exhorting people to vote and participate
in the political process doesn't seem to
really yield
higher amounts of participation in
America but it is really striking to me
as someone who follows civil rights
issues
how much disenfranchisement is moving
into the mainstream in American politics
you know it is true that we've had
people perpetuate myths about voter
fraud before but to have a vice
presidential commission in which you
have basically the four most extreme
people on the in the country empowered
to think about all the ways to use the
power of the federal government not to
enfranchise people but to actually make
it harder to vote that's the kind of
entrenchment of power that I think
connects to Tom and Aziz's work because
it's about the Constitution and it's you
know failures as well as its strengths
we don't have a clear right to vote in
the Constitution there's nothing that
says that we are supposed to prevent
unnecessary restrictions on voting and
we don't because of our amendment
process have a clear way to address that
either so that's a way I think in which
the structural challenges intersect with
these questions about coalition building
just to justify an example of maybe the
kind of politics that I was talking
about we have had a successful
left-of-centre or centrist political
movement in the country in the last six
months it's the movement to defend
Obamacare and it's a movement that
succeeded in in making it extremely
difficult to enact legislation that
strips away a form of social provision
that disproportionately benefits people
of color but it's a movement that in
part succeed succeeded paradoxically
because we have a antiquated
Constitution that creates probably far
too many veto games for the the optimal
constitutional design right so it's said
I think that there's a lesson there to
be had about the absolute the existence
of imminent political coalition's of the
sort that gutters
talking about but also the way the fair
when one is thinking if one is thinking
and with a political strategist at all
one needs to account for the ways in
which the institutional architecture
dozen does not create opportunities for
mobilization and mobilization of
different forms okay I have more
questions here then then will be
addressed particularly if we address
them as comprehensively as as we did the
last one but so this one was directed at
David but I actually think several of
the panelists might have something to to
say about the way was put in in the way
in the one was directed at David how do
we rebuild the bipartisan consensus
around small D democratic norms and a
sub question was what's the scenario
where internal GOP politics would
facilitate that process but also may be
internal Democratic Party politics might
be added to that that's a that's the
ultimate question and one of the maybe
before answering and I'll be brief I
invite people and this is may be
responsible y'all should just say to ask
yourself what are you trying to
accomplish here if what you're trying to
accomplish is how do we strengthen the
left that's one answer and you're saying
how do we try to strengthen democratic
norms that's quite a different answer
and there's been a tendency to blur them
the way I'm not on the person with the
left at all so I'll just give you four
Myositis me you wanna strengthen life
the way you do it is by ramping up is by
building a coalition of minorities
that's that's the best democratic
mobilization build-up racial antagonism
black lives matter those because of the
the big the reason that Hillary which
the reason the 2016 election was
abnormal was by the normal political
science indicators Hillary Clinton
should have won fifty three percent of
the vote the fact that she got forty
eight is abnormal she lost five points
in a very common friendly
environment why failure de mobilized
black voters partly because of voter
suppression partly because she wasn't
offering them much of anything Medicare
for all that that's how you build the
left but what you will discover when you
do that is the candidates who leave that
will be Trump's of the left not as gross
for example like Bernie Sanders who was
good at his job
yeah they won't they they will be norm
travelers they will do things like
Obama's executive actions to in his
second term that's what you'll get that
is a way to a more social democratic
United States it'll be an ethnically
driven way if what you want to do if
it's it but if your question is how do
we build democratic norms that's a
different question and then and and then
you have to say this is not about party
advantage and that means that some of
the people you have to address the
things that are driving the corrosion of
democratic norms what do you think was
you would you be a butter he said why
did you why did you vote for trouble and
by the voter said well you know I'm just
really disappointed and what is happened
to my personal living standard I've been
at a way wage increase in twenty years
saying you are so greedy and
materialistic don't you understand that
money is the root of all evil hi Colin I
caught you like order you delay aside
these crass okay but that is the sermon
that they get if they say I'm happy that
my sis my neighborhood which used to be
a hundred sailors percent
english-speaking now has 30 percent
English second language learners in my
children's school and that will happen I
went to a school in North Carolina what
does research in Oakland 20 in 2007
where family reported the change from no
foreign language speakers to 30 percent
over the course of their through
children's time in that one school
district if what finally what is
bothering and do something about and
take them and take the grievances
seriously I'm the trumpeter Jose
trumpeter is deeply at a stop but I had
a big impact on me the job that seems to
me that Democratic systems get into
trouble in two ways
one is when you put populist muses the
people identify the problems and the
people offer the solutions
bad lead ISM is the the people identify
problems the elites tell them they're
wrong about them and offer other
problems and other stages also bad
listen to the problems then then use
partisan competition to compete to offer
responsible solutions but do not read
the problems on court any anyone else
want to pick up any of that well there's
several questions that are basically
about the connections between populism
and presidential ism to what extent are
they some kind of you know symbiotic to
mutually encouraging or one one
producing the other or yeah I'm going to
be very brief this time but I'm gonna
make myself even more unpopular um if
there's one thing but all of political
scientists seem to agree on over the
last thirty years so that it's all about
institutions right and and it's not
clear to me in the case of populism but
it is now obviously the particular way
in which populism plays out in different
countries is shaped by institutions but
when you look around these different
contexts what is striking is that
populism has found a way of expressing
itself here for a presidential election
there threw a party was very strong in
Parliament there through you know a
popular referendum across all it is very
very different institutional context so
while I think was obviously things to be
said about hyper partisanship about
anger about the fact that the political
system is blocked because of all the
veto powers and all of those things the
United States what's striking to me when
you look at international perspective is
how little of the experience and the
variation of populism can be explained
by institutions
just add you know Viktor Orban era Diwan
came to power as Prime Minister you know
you go down the list and so to me what
this suggests is that old debate juan
linz his question actually in some ways
it was answered I think by Adams
students a chaemoo I don't know if you
stood but he answered it about a decade
ago you know that it's not presidential
ism or parliamentarism per se there's
selection issues which create the
outcomes we see and to me that suggests
a much more micro focus in terms of our
research agenda can I pop in I wrote a
book about mandates and presidential
mandate claiming and my argument in the
u.s. context is that populism is a
rhetorical strategy for presidents to
deal with the legitimacy challenges to
an incredibly powerful and problematic
institution and the conditions of
partisanship so I think this there's
something separate there about populism
as as a rhetorical strategy
well so here's one that this says it has
david firm's name at the top but that
may be a rhetorical sleight making
America great again would require
strengthening the welfare state which
many voters interpret us giving handouts
to blacks and Latinos these voters are
also the most vulnerable to
anti-immigrant and xenophobic appeals
would your concessions work question
mark did at one point endorse the
lowering of the age would qualification
for Medicare I think to 55 I forget that
was one of her 972 policy proposals and
one of the things I has always been a
theory of mind about campaigns as if you
have 1972 policy proposals you don't
have any if you have four you don't have
any if you have two you're testing
people's memory so if you yeah I think I
think generally I think you see
throughout the that the United States
needs a thicker Social Insurance network
Europe needs a thinner one we need ways
of financing it that are not too
provocative and you need you need an
offer but the offer the offer works
because it's an offer to the politic if
if the offer is to the planet then the
offer is going to break down to the tone
of its own way so I think actually the
two thing when you talk about it is not
that this there in this it is not a
contradiction that you have a policy of
thicker social insurance and higher
borders those two go hand-in-hand and
that's one of things by the way that
people want to break the welfare state
they understand that very well that's
that's why you find libertarians are
very committed to open borders because
they know with
orders your welfare system your social
service system cannot work and that's
why they're favored so a question for
for Emily and perhaps also Yasha there's
a deals party with social media
how can journalists deal with the
particular challenges of covering the
Trump presidency a that so much is
happening such that many important
stories get neglected and be that Trump
manages so often to dominate the news
cycle with tweets that derail attention
from substantive and timely issues
sometimes this seems to me like Trump's
main talent is that he has taken his
reality television show and turned it
into the news that we consume all the
time that is an inescapable and there's
a kind of fire hose and in fact there
are all kinds of teasers you know you'll
we'll see soon he's sort of using all
those strategies that served him in this
different role to great effect and it is
a huge challenge for the media you know
we cover everything it's just that
people can't really keep up and it
becomes harder and harder to know what's
important the 972 points
kind of hold in that era as well you
know one part of the media that I
probably should have mentioned and
didn't it's obvious is that um you know
the right-wing media has become has
taken on such a role in fueling social
media in covering the president in a
different way and I think that again
that puts pressure on the mainstream
media to become kind of a different
animal and responds in a way that were
not particularly well suited for um I do
think one thing the mainstream media has
doing been doing better at is covering
fake news as fake news as opposed to
ignoring it even last year you see a
fake news story you just sort of like
act as if that's you're not gonna touch
that as opposed to trying is realizing
that it's out there being consumed and
needs to be debunked and it's always
tricky debunking also you know spreads
misinformation too but I think we're at
the point
given how people are consuming news how
difficult it is to tell on Facebook
whether the source you're looking at is
credible or not that the mainstream
media has a responsibility to be
engaging in these stories that we used
to see as beneath us yeah so I mean
i-i've been thinking through sort of the
different notions of truth and lies we
have right so those this pair of
concepts that were very popular a few
years ago so Stephen Colbert's
truthiness and when Harry Frankfurt on
[ __ ] which is basically saying the
problem isn't isn't any more of a sort
of straightforward lies for problem now
that people are sort of indifferent to
the truth and we don't quite know how to
deal with that and that's different from
the straightforward lie because at least
there's a how Frankfurt ones at least
Valaya pays it kind of tribute to the
truth right I actually think that that
in retrospect is really naive that
compared to what we have now
that sort of child's play but what you
see and I think the first place where I
observed it actually was Italy and a
silhou Bella's kony but I think Donald
Trump is completely following that part
of Paris Coney's example it's it's it's
over frating the public of so many false
claims and with just so much spectacle
and with so many things going on that it
becomes impossible for people to
ascertain what's true or not because if
you have a normal sort of attention span
to politics which is to say a fraction
of that of what most people in this room
whose life it is to study politics half
you just cannot no longer it's the
opposite of what David was saying what a
policy promise it's not one lie that is
defining of your presidency you do 10
lies a day and so nobody in the you know
in 98 percent of population don't have a
patience to try and figure out with
details on each of those claims and so
all you can do is to trust the people
whom you trust and if you're on the
right that'll mean you know Fox News or
to the right lad and if it's on the left
it means you know the kinds of things we
must be probably consumed right and I
think there's a difference between those
two I'm not saying but we're the same
but but but I at this point don't have
the time and the patience to go through
every claim and
make my own assessment as to whether
Donald Trump is actually true in bout
racist things he claims a happening I
simply assume that they're false because
he has managed to over freight the
system so much but there's no other way
of dealing with that I'm a diving is a
fundamental attack on the very
possibility of having a truth based
discourse or a political discourse in
which truth sort of negotiates how we
should act though we haven't quite faced
up to conceptually much less in terms of
our response to it can I say something
very brief about this very brief yeah
it's a question actually you know Trump
has a big Twitter following but you know
when you tweet something it might get
retweeted I don't know ten twenty thirty
thousand times it's nothing like Kim
Kardashian right so my question is why
is it that every tweet is news why is
the mega the megaphone is actually the
New York Times printing you know
treating his tweet as news and I wonder
how you guys think about that so it does
seem that the subject no I'm sorry
oh you want an answer to that well
you're gonna get the penultimate worries
well and also this is just like
everything turns into my trying to
answer for the New York Times right I
don't even work on the news desk but
look the president is making statements
right I mean I don't know if you all
notice the Twitter account that turns
every tweet into an official statement
but ridiculous as it is that is what
they are and so then you have to make
judgments as the news desk every day
that covers the president well which of
these really matter and that is hard to
do there is no question that there's all
kinds of chaff with the weed but that is
a tough decision for a journalist to
make something the president says
something provocative isn't newsworthy
the problem with the refusal to stay
away is we have things like you know the
four days during Puerto Rico where
Puerto Rico is a nun television because
there's no electricity there and it's
very hard to get images and instead
we're having some made-up fight about
you know Colin Kaepernick and Steph
Curry and the and black athletes which
is simply divisive it's that is tough
for journalists to push back on
and one sentence I know this is will be
to your question the fact that the
statements don't matter is why they
matter so when the President of the
United States the commander-in-chief of
the Armed Forces says with an eight and
a half minute gap in between to give the
Russians lots of time to get off a
nuclear missile response I am about to
announce a total and complete ban on dot
transgender soldiers in the military and
then the military says thank you for
your helpful comment we certainly will
take it into consideration
and give it to and the military's
actually no we thought it over we're
sticking to our original policy because
it's tweetIn that's astonishing that's
an amazing thing and the fact we have
this decision of government where the
president proposes ideas from time to
time and the Secretary of Defense
determines whether they'll become
government policy we we are out of time
I would just say that I think it's
fitting since we are a university that
the subject of truth is where we've
we've ended up we are after all our
basic mission is the creation and
dissemination of knowledge and you know
some might might go so far as to say
that the the movements within
universities to question whether it's
possible to actually generate nevermind
disseminate knowledge have have created
part of the intellectual and ideological
terrain that makes what we've been
talking about for the last five minutes
possible and perhaps in addition to
being public intellectuals are coming
out of our our ivory towers and speaking
in the public sphere we might want to
pay some attention to the the recreation
of norms of truth-telling and truth
seeking within our own institutions but
I want to thank everybody for
participating and particularly the
people have done all a tremendous amount
of work to come here
thank you all very much indeed
[Applause]
[Music]